ah
una semana más en el conflicto de
ucrania una semana en la que el foco de
la atención estuvo en la evacuación de
civiles que estaban refugiados durante
semanas en la planta metalúrgica de asof
tal en el asediado puerto de mariupol en
el siguiente informe recogemos algunos
de los testimonios y hechos de lo
sucedido en esa planta
32 meses encerrada en un búnker en
azores tal y tiana trotz ayc disfruta de
su primer día de libertad bañado por el
sol esa polilla escapar y estar bajo el
cielo tranquilo míralo azul y brillante
es pacífico gracias a dios no hay
sonidos de explosiones
espero que acá nunca haya ningún tipo de
estruendo solo fuegos artificiales y
truenos firmar clímax y monroe junto a
su marido y sus padres de tiendas se
refugió en uno de los búnkeres de la
acería de azov tal fuertemente
bombardeada por rusia una realidad que
compartió con más de 50 personas
incluidos niños de los cuales sólo sabe
de 14 que han logrado escapar asdru
western estoy terriblemente preocupada
por los civiles y los soldados heridos
que siguen allí está más tarde
hasta el extraño en la ciudad al pasar
por la planta anteayer vimos que todo el
día en un monegro como muchas otras
familias la dt tiana tuvo que [__]
algunas de sus pertenencias y huir a un
refugio cuando un proyectil cayó cerca
de su casa en marzo también se viste soy
listo
tuvimos una reunión familiar y decidimos
que algo malo estaba pasando lo mejor
era que nos fuéramos a un lugar más
alejado mi madre trabajaba en la planta
de as hostal en el departamento de
ferrocarriles sabía que ya había un
refugio antibombas en el edificio
administrativo boca de administración de
ambos cuerpos las autoridades calculan
que al menos 200 civiles siguen
atrapados en los búnkeres de la fábrica
de acero diariamente son muchas personas
de mariupol que llegan a favor y ya en
busca de su relativa seguridad
el alcalde de la ciudad de mariupol
indicó que perdió toda comunicación con
los militares y con los civiles que
permanecen en el interior de esta planta
sobre este tema se pronunció sviatoslav
para la mar el comandante adjunto del
regimiento a soft de ucrania
ashton gloria ucrania es el tercer día
que el enemigo ha entrado en la planta
siderúrgica total se están llevando a
cabo intensos y sangrientos combates
durante 71 días los defensores de la
ciudad han estado luchando solos contra
las fuerzas enemigas abrumadoras otra
vez los rusos no han cumplido la promesa
de una actual fuego y no han dado una
oportunidad a los civiles que buscan
refugio en los sótanos de la planta 1 el
cual según dijo es zip equipo 2 hago un
llamado a la comunidad mundial para que
evacuen a los civiles y hago un llamado
personalmente al comandante supremo para
que saque a los soldados heridos que
sufren un dolor terrible muriendo a
causa de sus heridas sin el tratamiento
necesario
en el otro lado rusia ha reiterado que
sus fuerzas armadas no son las autoras
de los recientes ataques en la planta de
la sof tal que es prácticamente una
ciudad dentro de la misma ciudad de
mariupol así lo indicó dmitri peskov el
portavoz del kremlin escuchemos
nuestro presidente comandante supremo
dio públicamente la orden de abstenerse
de lanzar un ataque no se han anunciado
otras órdenes y los corredores
humanitarios están en funcionamiento
allí hoy y en los últimos días también
para destacar de esta semana la posición
de la unión europea que ha considerado
brindar apoyo militar adicional a
moldavia así lo confirmó el presidente
del consejo de la unión europea charles
michel
recordemos que moldavia es una ex
república soviética que tiene ya un
largo conflicto en la región de
transnistria que es una región
separatista prorrusa que podría ser
aprovechada estratégicamente por moscú
para invadir el oeste de ucrania también
para destacar esta semana la visita de
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi que
llegó a kiev la capital ucraniana en
señal de apoyo al gobierno ucraniano
estados unidos.en reiteró su apoyo
militar a ucrania entretanto también
fueron dadas a conocer las imágenes de
kiev la capital ucraniana después de los
ataques de la semana pasada ataques
perpetrados con arsenal militar ruso las
evidencias son clarísimas veamos
lo que hasta hace pocas semanas era
material de combate hoy son obras de
exposición a las afueras del museo
nacional de historia militar de ucrania
en kiev se han expuesto los restos de
armamento del ejército ruso destruido
durante las semanas más duras de la
ofensiva rusa en la capital los
transeúntes caminan ahora porque es
entre pedazos de aviones y tanques de
combate se paran comentan e incluso se
toman fotos para algunos la exposición
de la destrucción del material de las
tropas del kremlin es un golpe a la
moral y les hace creer que la victoria
está más cerca para otros este material
debe permanecer expuesto para honrar la
historia
cuantos más vehículos enemigos
destruidos tengamos más cerca estará la
victoria
hace q tiernos brotes hay que recopilar
este material en lugares especiales para
crear museos lugares en los que se pueda
entrar y sumergirse en los recuerdos
dispongas en la misma línea se expresa
pablo net soft combatiente veterano
ucraniano quien manifestó que la
exposición del armamento ruso en la
capital es un acto para preservar la
historia
se trata de la preservación real de la
historia para que nadie puede decir no
ocurrió
el tiempo pasará y ya no habrá nada que
ver según el veterano de guerra es
importante que los civiles que
regresaron a kiev después de que la
ofensiva rusa se concentrará en el
donbass vean la magnitud de la guerra
frente a sus ojos
a través de esta exhibición de
equipamiento militar quiero que la gente
entienda esta guerra como yo la veo como
está sucediendo en realidad wards son
los prop
mientras las autoridades ucranianas
sostienen que el objetivo actual de
moscú pasa por hacerse con el control
total de las autoproclamadas repúblicas
de lugansk doñetsk en kiev los vestigios
de la ofensiva rusa conviven con una
extraña vuelta a la cotidianidad ya
tenemos entonces un poco más claro el
panorama de lo sucedido en la semana así
las cosas entonces hoy en france 24 en
el debate analizamos los hechos más
recientes de la guerra en ucrania y el
impacto que esto va a tener en el
desarrollo de este conflicto para los
días que vienen para analizar este tema
saludamos a la doctora diana ibáñez ella
es antropóloga social en la universidad
de sussex ella es especialista en temas
de asia central también en lengua y
cultura persa y rusa se encuentra en la
ciudad de londres en el reino unido- y
también se une a esta conversación pablo
hernández analista especializado en
historia rusa también historia militar y
docente de la universidad interamericana
él se encuentra en ciudad de san juan en
la isla de puerto rico
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
pueden participar en este debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas lo pueden
hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook
también en instagram y en twitter
ustedes ya lo saben estamos como
france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal les
recuerdo nuestra etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y preguntas en torno a este
tema sabemos que en redes sociales este
tema despierta mucho interés por parte
de la audiencia latinoamericana comienza
entonces preguntándole a la doctora
adriana ibáñez en la ciudad de londres
sobre el asedio a la planta de s'hostal
las dificultades que ha habido para
poder sacar a los civiles a través de
esos corredores humanitarios las
versiones contrarias que hay por parte
de kiev y moscú y lo que representaría
el asedio a mariupol y a esta planta
metalúrgica para el desarrollo de este
conflicto como lo vio usted doctora
bienvenida
hola buenas buenas tardes muchas gracias
bueno hay que recordar que mario pool es
una de las ciudades claves en esta
invasión rusa y ucrania porque es la
salida que están buscando los rusos
hacia el mar de azov entonces es
extremadamente estratégica y por eso ha
sido una de las ciudades
han sido prioridad de las tropas rusas
desde el principio y ha sido una ciudad
ha estado en disputa desde el 2014 con
las primeras escaramuzas y el inicio de
esta guerra en la región de donbass y
marío paul era uno de los puntos
estratégicos a la planta de s'hostal hay
que tomar en cuenta que es una planta
muy grande como como se mencionaban él
hace unos momentos era es una planta que
son 11 kilómetros cuadrados y que tiene
redes de trenes red de subterráneos
oficinas y demás entonces es un punto
estratégico donde civiles así como la
resistencia ucraniana ha tomado refugio
y entonces esto es uno de los puntos
donde se ha estado haciendo más batallas
aunque el gobierno ruso bueno está
mencionando que no que no va haber más
ofensiva a los corredores humanitarios
se ha mencionado mucho sobre los
corredores humanitarios no solamente en
mario pool sino en otras ciudades de
rusia y es algo que las organizaciones
internacionales humanitarias han estado
apoyando pero
y la logística de estos corredores
humanitarios es muy compleja sobre todo
porque estos corredores humanitarios son
para sacar a poblaciones civiles
en ciudades o puntos específicos
estratégicos donde hay la mayor parte de
la guerra y de los celos
donde puede haber bajas civiles claro
se dan muchas
formas de comunicación y de comunicación
que pueden romper los acuerdos para
sacar poblaciones su víctima les esto
estaba pasando en varias ciudades
en estas semanas se sacaron 200 civiles
de la planta de asof tal pero es muy
complicado porque la resistencia
ucraniana está mezclada con tropas
militares tropas ucranianas bien armadas
y también civiles entonces es bastante
complicado sacar por los corredores
humanitarios a poblaciones civiles claro
de hace pocos minutos o hace algunas
horas fue anunciado que tal vez podría
establecerse un tercer corredor para
sacar a otros 100 civiles que se creen
entre 100 y 200 civiles que todavía
están al interior de la planta le doy la
palabra ahora a pablo hernández en la
ciudad de san juan en puerto rico y le
doy la bienvenida también al programa
pablo quiero preguntarle por la
importancia de esta planta es uno de los
rezagos industriales que dejó la unión
soviética de este poderío mineral
industrial que tenía la unión soviética
en el territorio ucraniano tiene cierto
simbolismo para moscú y para rusia que
significaría para este conflicto que
cayera finalmente esta planta
metalúrgica de gran tamaño como ésta lo
describía la doctora ibáñez para el
ejército ruso
bueno
creo creo que no puedo no puedo evitar
buscar una analogía cuando me estaba
hablando de una planta metalúrgica
dedicada al equipo pesado construida en
la unión soviética
y no puedo dejar identificar mario
publicó una versión está en grado las
dos se se libran como expresión de una
resistencia de renovado contra un
enemigo superior en unas condiciones de
desventaja y de un virtual cerco en el
caso de marie paule es completamente y
como aquí es el símbolo del poderío de
la industrialización de esa pretensión
soviética siempre dan a la industria
pesada la naturaleza fundamental de la
expresión del poderío del estado hoy se
convierte en símbolo de una resistencia
nacionalista
precisamente
encaminada a enfrentar el
enfrentar un poder luz enfrentar un
poderoso que es manifiesta totalmente en
precisamente por lo es por los productos
de la industria pesada con un uso de la
artillería bestiario estaba viendo hoy
que prácticamente se está peleando ya
dentro de
de la acería o sea que está parece que
estuviera viendo el episodio de la
fábrica de tractores stalingrado porque
esto es casi casi algo digo no es
similar pero uno no puede evitar como
historiador ver ciertas de
los puntos de contacto pero
evidentemente es un símbolo de la era
soviética que hoy se convierte en un
baluarte que le ha roto los dientes al
ejército ruso me parece que sin un ritmo
duro
es inevitable hacer esa comparación
stalingrado fue una de las ciudades que
vivió uno de los ataques más
complejos y largos a lo largo de la
segunda guerra mundial entre los nazis y
el ejército rojo hoy en día la ciudad se
llama a polvo grado cambio de nombre
después de la caída de la unión
soviética pablo continuó con usted para
hacerle otra pregunta puntual ya le doy
la palabra la doctora ibáñez quiero
preguntarle pablo desde su punto de
vista
qué logros alcanzado rusia y el
presidente vladimir putin en estos cerca
de 70 días de combates de incursión
militar de esta misión como ellos la han
llamado desde el kremlin ha habido algún
algún triunfo considerable sí yo creo
que sí primero unificar occidente
segundo la gente mostrar a nivel mundial
que hay líder del calibre de excelencia
y que hay pueblos como el ucraniano que
son capaces de pelear en desventaja se
suponía que en el siglo 21 eso no se
llevaba pero la
realidad nos da sorpresa conseguir que
finlandia y suecia se unan a la otan con
de conseguir un repudio casi universal y
cualquier visión positiva que se podía
haber tenido de rusia en los últimos 30
años destruirla y
convertir a putin el archivillano
por excelencia de nuestra época algo que
de verdad que habría que ir bastante
atrás para encontrar un sujeto en árbol
además
involucrar lucía en una guerra que me
imagino que a los generales rusos no le
traerá solo los sinsabores de chechenia
sino también los malos recuerdos de
afganistán claro y al pueblo ruso de no
tener víctimas por ambiciones desmedidas
de sus gobernantes que está jugando el
imperio además añadiría yo a su análisis
pablo
un poco dañar esos 30 años que le ha
costado a rusia volver a posicionarse a
nivel internacional como una potencia
como un líder político que le ha costado
mucho creo que esto sin duda alguna
afecta el posicionamiento de rusia
a nivel internacional doctora ibáñez no
me olvide de usted por supuesto le doy
ahora la palabra para que si quiere
complementar algo sobre el triunfo que
puede verse desde la perspectiva del
kremlin como un triunfo para para rusia
en este en este conflicto con los hechos
de la última semana y también
preguntarle por la situación del
presidente putin a nivel interno quienes
siguen apoyando al presidente dentro de
rusia cómo está el apoyo del presidente
también se especula mucho en occidente
sobre la salud del presidente putin que
está enfermo y que podría estar
padeciendo alguna enfermedad que lo
podría apartar del poder en unos cuantos
meses son especulaciones que hay en
occidente que se sabe que se puede
analizar desde el lado ruso
si primero quiero complementar lo que lo
que hablaba
doctor pablo sobre los
intentos imperialistas rusos que están
erosionando los 30 años de diplomacia
internacional y el posicionamiento de
rusia en lo que se pensaba en era una
nueva diplomacia global
y está mostrando estos nuevos intentos
de imperio y creo que una de las de los
efectos importantes además de estar
haciendo avances aunque sea bastante
lentos y bastante complicados en ucrania
por la resistencia que hay
si hay un efecto simbólico muy fuerte es
un efecto donde países como moldavia por
ejemplo están ya temiendo que este
imperialismo ruso siga avanzando lo
mismo con los estados del báltico
porque una de las de las razones el
gobierno ruso el gobierno de putin
alegra para la incursión en ucrania es
precisamente la protección de ciudadanos
rusos dentro del país y de la lengua
rusa
y desde desde los años noventas en todo
lo que era la parte ex soviética los
nuevos países a los regímenes más
nacionalistas de asia central del
báltico o moldavia el cáucaso danés está
incursionando para hacer nuevas medidas
de promoción nacional de empezar a
enseñar sus sus lenguas en las escuelas
en lugar del ruso entonces muchos de
estos países están
temen al mismo tiempo que europa
occidental teme que las incursiones
rusas puedan seguir esa misma
legitimación entonces creo que hay un
daño simbólico importante
no solamente porque rusia ya también
tuvo incursiones en georgia por ejemplo
y bueno tiene el territorio de
transnistria en moldavia entonces los
países del báltico también temen que
pueda haber una expansión real y que
esto no haga en ucrania
claro en cuanto al gobierno y al apoyo
en rusia a putin
cabe destacar que putin ha tenido una
política que ha acercado su gobierno
cerrando muchas formas de oposición
cerrando muchas formas de
expresión pública poco a poco y muchas
de la de la oposición a su gobierno de
la sociedad civil han estado
escapando de rusia desde hace mucho
tiempo refugiándose en europa esto es
son artistas intelectuales y demás y una
gran parte de la población rusa apoya la
invasión y muchos otros no entienden por
qué
bueno rusia entienden al pueblo
ucraniano doctor pueblo hermano
y no lo entienden y hay hay pocos
intelectuales yo creo que la minoría y
artistas y demás que se oponen pero pero
ahí
pueden terminar en la cárcel por por
llevar la contraria al gobierno de putin
los casos los hemos visto ya voy pasando
ya la mitad del programa y tengo muchos
temas para tratar en doctora quiero
hablar con usted por una fecha muy
importante y es el 9 de mayo estamos ya
a la vuelta de la esquina de llegar a
esa fecha es una fecha importante para
rusia históricamente hacia el día de la
victoria y hay mucha especulación a
nivel internacional sobre lo que puede
pasar o ser anunciado ese día por parte
desde moscú se especula que puede ser el
anuncio del fin de esta operación
militar rusa en ucrania puede ser el
anuncio de la declaración de guerra
formal contra las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas y contra el gobierno y
también se especula sobre una posible
proclamación definitiva
independencia y separación de ucrania de
las repúblicas populares de donestsk y
lugansk y análisis se puede hacer al
respecto le pido por favor sea muy
concreta porque ya me queda poco tiempo
para finalizar el programa y debo
analizar otros temas
si definitivamente yo no creo que el
gobierno ruso vaya a anunciar el fin de
esta de esta invasión de esta guerra
porque no han asegurado los territorios
que están en disputa
posiblemente se pueda anunciar la
separación de bombas y la
anexarse a rusia pero yo creo que es más
una es una fecha simbólica una fecha que
se ha usado porque se ha usado mucho
la idea de luchar ante los nazis se ha
llamado al batallón de asobal la
resistencia ucraniana como como una
resistencia pro nazi se han usado mucho
estas estas
formas de referirse a un conflicto para
llamar la atención y para llamar el
apoyo público de rusia esta invasión
no quiero hacer
especulaciones yo en realidad no creo
que vaya a pasar algo más significativo
que si es un simbolismo muy fuerte para
el apoyo hacia el gobierno y pablo cuál
es su perspectiva sobre la importancia
de la fecha del 9 de mayo fecha en que
conmemora en el día de la victoria
cuando el ejército rojo triunfo sobre la
alemania nazi lo que puede ser anunciado
bueno en realidad una acotación
histórica los alemanes se rindieron el
día 8 pero se rindieron james en francia
a los aliados y entonces los soviéticos
le exigieron al mando aliado que fueran
a ver línea firmarlo el 9 de mayo
entonces ellos se anotan la fiesta del 9
de mayo digo eso porque para contribuir
a que putin no la tenga tan fácil es el
campo histórico es un día que está lleno
de carga en la era soviética
por la que putin siente cierta debilidad
por lo menos ceremonial era una época
de gran despliegue de armamento yo
pienso que putin va a exhibir sus armas
las que ha utilizado y las que piensa
usar
tanto para el público para levantar el
fervor nacionalista del pueblo ruso que
es muy sensible a esto como para enviar
los mensajes no muy subliminales a sus
adversarios estando los ucranianos como
los occidentales es posible que quizás
en la tarima computen externo
representante de las repúblicas
populares de en cuestión del don ex
desde lugares quizás pues proclame que
pronto se va a ser la de ejerció niza
policial sólo eso es posible porque
estaría en la ritualidad
también los discursos del 9 de mayo
podían ser discursos que si no decían
insinuaban pero también voy a seguir los
mismos
a sugerencia de la colega la doctora
ibáñez y no presumir pero si tiene una
carga simbólica
si tiene evidentemente el sacar por la
plaza roja y desfilar frente a la tumba
de lenin o que tengan montada la tarima
en otra ocasión se va a hacer el músculo
militar que es lo que ha representado
siempre podrido de rusia en cualquier
región y el aussie yo creo que ellos lo
van a echar y quizás alguno que otro
trofeo capturado los ucraniano cuidado
porque yo también
quizás sea algo muy tártaro y muy mongol
que han conservado lo ruso todo de pasar
a lo sé prisionero o por la plaza roja
quizá no creo que tenga que exigir mucho
pero pudiera ser si ese es el escenario
perfecto para hacer ese tipo de rituales
que es prácticamente algo parte ya de la
tradición rusa a lo largo de todos estos
años no solamente lo vimos en la época
soviética sino también en la época
imperial hace ya unos cuantos siglos
atrás quiero hablar con ustedes sobre el
tema de moldavia lo mencionaba al inicio
del programa la unión europea está
dispuesta a enviar armas a este país un
país muy pobre del este de europa que
está tratando de incorporarse a la unión
europea ha firmado algunos documentos
para hacer un país candidato está en
este proceso que todavía le falta muchas
fases pero es una ex república soviética
y eso la compromete históricamente con
moscú y tiene el problema de
transnistria que lo hemos explicado y ha
hablado acá
en el debate esta ayuda militar que
podría llegar doctora y baños que podría
llegar al territorio moldavo podría
despertar preocupación por parte de
moscú sentiría el kremlin amenazas
directas por parte de la otan o la unión
europea si entran armas a territorio
moldavo
de moldavia está siendo uno de los
escenarios bastante complicados y
peligrosos dentro de esta invasión a
ucrania
sobre todo por
transnistria que es una parte pequeña de
moldavia muy significativa que en los
noventas rusia proclamó como como
independiente un poco como lo que lo que
ha querido hacer con la región de dones
y los hanes en ucrania entonces fue fue
un proceso muy similar
yo estuve un poco antes de covite en el
2019 en transnistria y eso fue
interesante ver como la frontera de
transnistria está rodeada por oro
oficiales rusos hay un paso para por
ejemplo de pasaporte y demás
qué es ruso y esto está desde los 90s en
un conflicto con moldavia moldavia
evidentemente como ucrania con dos dones
y luján se reclama que transmitir es es
moldavia no no es independiente ni es
parte de rusia y la mayoría de la
comunidad internacional no reconocen a
taxista como un estado independiente
sientes
que podría así llegan armas procedentes
de la unión europea este territorio si
el hecho de que esté llegando ayuda a
moldavia es evidentemente una amenaza
directa a la presencia de rusia en
transnistria hubo ya algunos
aparentemente
bombardeos que los premios dice son los
rusos los rusos dicen que son los
ucranianos
ya ha habido hay provocaciones entonces
es algo que hay que mantener
a la vista porque es importante pablo
desde el contexto histórico
moldavia podría ser la próxima ucrania y
ahora que podrían entrar armas de la
unión europea esto podría generar
problemas con moscú
el problema como existe desde el año 94
por lo menos cuando los rusos decidieron
no
respetar los acuerdos y
retirar su fuerza yo creo que el
ejército de voltar ya tiene en 3.250
hombre o sea que a los rusos no le debe
dar un gran a gran preocupación
aunque reciba asistencia occidental que
la ha recibido los americanos y creo que
los alemanes le pasaron infórmate
información y armamento hace unos años
ya creo que después del caso de crimea
ahora bien yo creo que el temor de ello
hay que moldavia cualquier relación que
se pueda consolidar entre moldavia y
rumanía por la relación histórica por la
relación étnica y porque una moldavia
reforzada
evidentemente amparado por rumanía pues
pondría transnistria en una situación
más precaria en la que está ahora yo
estaba viendo un informe de hoy del
instituto para el estudio de la guerra
el grupo de estudios rusos que estaba
sugiriendo que este despliegue que los
rusos han insinuado
para reforzar y transmitir desde el aire
desde el crimen no es más con movimiento
diversionista para mover fuerzas de la
defensa del distrito de odessa hacia la
frontera del cni esther y debilitar el
sector defensivo de mi cola jr odessa y
es posible y eso está en que haya una
ofensiva subsidiaria desde la línea la
dirección gerson nikoláy en ese entonces
puede tener
en la función de crearle a los
ucranianos un problema en la frontera
puede ser como es un punto de freaks y
ccoo por la otan porque está en un país
neutral pero que está atrapado
prácticamente entre 2 beligerancia pero
esté ese lugar puede ser perfectamente
ese mecanismo que haga que los
ucranianos miren al oeste sé cuando en
el este pudieran estar ese es un
escenario complejo técnicamente complejo
históricamente complejo
estratégicamente por complejos
políticamente complejo porque paul davis
arabes arabia de las tierras que más
demás manos han pasado en la que los
rusos están interesados del siglo 18
claro ya me quedan pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa doctora quiero a
cerrar con esos comentarios que hizo el
presidente selenski que volvió a hacer
un llamado a la rápida incorporación de
ucrania en la unión europea esto es
posible en la práctica esto en que
cambiaría el escenario del conflicto muy
puntual por favor
si
evidentemente selenski ha
continuado haciendo un llamado a la
incorporación a la unión europea a la
incorporación de la otan para defender a
ucrania y no no no es un proceso fácil y
no es un proceso que la unión europea o
la otan estén dispuestos a
a incorporar a ucrania dentro de la
unión europea o al out and a
incorporarse en el conflicto creo que va
a ser un apoyo indirecto o sea el apoyo
en cuanto a armas financiamiento ayuda
humanitaria a refugiados y demás va a
continuar ahí pero va a ser un
[Música]
una implicación indirecta de la unión
europea y de la otan en ucrania yo no
veo ningún escenario a corto plazo para
que
ucrania entre la unión europea o la otan
entre directamente del golpe para bloy
desde su perspectiva que puede suceder
entonces en este conflicto para los
próximos días yo siempre lo digo al
cierre del programa no tenemos bola de
cristal para conocer el futuro de las
coyunturas que estamos analizando pero
en que cree usted que puede suceder en
los próximos días y qué rumbo puede
tomar esto yo creo que si los ucranianos
mantienen el mismo temple el mismo valor
y la misma determinación y los
occidentales el compromiso moral y
material de auxiliarlo
se va a prolongar en una lucha que va a
estar centrada en yo pienso que la pelea
va a estar ahí en esa
posible bolsa de bombas
creo que esto se puede puede tomar un
tiempo más creo que no va a haber una
determinación fulgurante y ojalá que los
a la larga los ucranianos prevalezcan y
ojalá que en rusia hubiese pues una
especie de iluminación o un general
afortunado que nos ayudará a buscar la
la solución a esto de una forma que es
que fuera no hubo violencia y si con
negociación pero como veo las cosas la
pelea va a ser dura
cruda y sangrienta por lo menos en la
semana que viene no quiero pasar no sé
doctora diana su conclusión que sigue
para este conflicto como lo ve usted si
este conflicto empezó hace ocho años lo
que pasa es que no se puso toda la
atención que merecía no se creyó que
pudiera incursionar más allá de donbass
y se anexionó crimea entonces esto tiene
8 años ya yo no veo coincido con el
doctor pablo yo no veo que esto vaya a
acabar la semana la semana entrante
desafortunadamente yo creo que va a
llevar más semanas sino meses
para concluir y mientras tanto pues
muchos desplazados muchos refugiados 5.7
millones de refugiados en europa
occidental
una destrucción masiva de
infraestructura
y de vidas humanas
lamentable lo que está sucediendo allí
tengo tiempo para hacerle una pregunta
corta a pablo antes del cierre del
programa quiero preguntarle por las
sanciones del sexto paquete que impuso
la unión europea hungría y eslovaquia se
opusieron porque son países que dependen
del petróleo de hidrocarburos
procedentes de rusia si están
funcionando las sanciones esto si está
apretando económicamente a rusia como
esperaba a bruselas y washington
voy a citar lo que digo hoy un
funcionario de la unión europea que dijo
que las sanciones eran efectivas pero a
largo plazo a muy largo plazo pero lo
que necesitaban los ucranianos junto con
las sanciones eran armas efectivas
modernas y el flujo continuado yo
coincido de que las sanciones harán daño
porque a la larga hacen daño porque la
guerra económica y una de las guerras
más devastadoras pero la guerra
económica es acumulativa y hoy la pelea
se está en campo de batalla que están
muriendo ucranianos y está muriendo
lamentablemente civiles y se está
muriendo soldados y también están
muriendo soldados rusos y hay madres
sufriendo y hay ciudades devastadas
miles de refugiados es una vergüenza que
hayan 10 millones de refugiados
producto esta guerra pero de dos meses
que es un nexo aquí para equiparable en
que se produjo en el frente oriental que
hace
setenta y pico de años claro
evidentemente las sanciones van a
funcionar pero
mientras tanto hay que actuar y hay que
darle a los graneros lo que ellos
necesitan para pagar la invasión se les
habla
y quiero agradecer a pablo hernández ya
la doctora adriana ibáñez por haber
estado con nosotros aquí en el programa
haber hecho este análisis muchos temas
para abarcar a lo largo de esta semana
pero hicimos el análisis por lo menos de
los puntos principales a los dos
muchísimas gracias y ustedes puede
seguir dejando sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales siga con nosotros
hay más información en france 24
[Música]